three signs that Russia is preparing for  all-out war number one Moscow police  officers are being taken out of the city  to learn how to shoot machine guns and  throw grenades usually they've only ever  had to train with a pistol and they've  never had to travel out of town for it  but now machine guns grenades and  military marching are all required  number two Moscow and other cities are  reportedly setting up bomb shelters for  their population shelters are being set  up in hospitals clinics the basements of  residential buildings and more number  three the Kremlin and Russia's  parliament are practicing emergency  evacuation drills that involve threats  of a terrorist nature against officials  something big is brewing subscribe for  updates